yohannes for you how is that as an actor
are you conscious of the camera being on
you mmm I think we were quite conscious
with the camera because Rubin is like
shooting between 30 and 50 takes each
scene and so we start off would like ten
scenes and our 1010 shots do you say
that ten takes and takes yeah and then
he take a pause for evaluation and
everybody'd go go to get to see the
scene that we were doing and everybody
tried to do their best to to make that
it really work so it was the first time
that i was i was invited to see what i
actually thought did and that was that
there was a nice way of working
sometimes you feel sometimes you feel
that you did a very good good scene but
then you see it or oh my feelings I it's
not there and it can be a very small
things would you show him the dailies
sorry yeah what we were shooting uh-huh
yeah I guess so and I guess since we are
working with a visual expression and it
it's as you said you're on is it not
about how you feel it but it's about
what it looks like so sometimes you can
show the scene for the actors and thank
you see okay maybe I should change in
this what I'm doing here and try to
express this in another way so I
actually that I know that some directors
don't want anybody to see what what they
are shooting and want to be the only one
that is control of the picture but I
think actually that it can help the
actors to see themselves from the
outside and i really be be very aware of
the small small details on how their
body language is or the way the way they
pronounce the dialogue and things like
that how was it for you to watch
yourself there's some actors that don't
want to see themselves yeah i'm actually
i'm like that then i'm not i'm not a
virus to myself right this is not matter
what i mean but
but I I tried to to see myself as an
object why did he do that why didn't you
do like this or this um so I think I
think actors should be able to see
themselves it can help them move I guess
I mean the scenes where I mean the
painful since when you were crying
strating I didn't say that I didn't see
it now yeah you didn't want to know
you